Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do: No showing bad movies to SCP-682!
SCP-682 is famous for a lot of things: its
indestructible nature, its insatiable appetite
for violence, and the overflowing well of
hate in its heart.
Unsatisfied with SCP-682's ordinary level
of rage, Dr. Bright decided to take it upon
himself to give the lizard even more things
to be angry about, and organized an informal
"so bad it's good" film festival for the anomaly
and himself.
The resulting damage, and loss of life, cost
the Foundation thousands of dollars.
Movies on the "do not show to 682 list" include:
The work of Uwe Boll, the work of Neil Breen,
The Room, Troll 2, Manos: The Hands of Fate,
and, let's face it, any other movie Dr. Bright
can think of.
No more movies.